hello everyone welcome back to the 2019
3d World Cup
it's Jeffress young versus young
Schuester Duda now in the previous game
we've shown do that one a very nice game
with the white pieces and well now
Jeffrey has to win on demand if he
doesn't want to be eliminated from the
feeder World Cup a lot of he'll already
suggested this game and for a very good
reason so let's just enjoy it with the
white pieces shield opens with E 4 with
E 5 and now Bishop to c4 he goes for the
bishops opening tried to mix it up as he
has to win this game with Knight to f6
and now d3 now we have c6 preparing d5
Knight to f3 and now of course the d5
but back to b3 and Bishop to b4 check
Duda is now following a game he already
played against Peter Svidler in the
rafita Grand Prix in Riga in July that
ended in a draw
Bishop the d2 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Queen to d6 developing
the Queen here defending d5 pawn and
Queen to g5 attacking the g7 pawn with
Knight B to d7 offering the g7 pawn for
a lot of activity of course after rope
to h8 but of course the point is not to
be captured ich a person B 5c captures
and now comes d4 with E for everything
the same as in the Phaedo grand prix
game against Peter Svidler but the
difference is fiddler played nice to h4
here whereas nice to e5 here by fume
it's not a new move it has been played
before in one game V Google versus Zubov
in 2016 but again it will take a
different turn of course with castles
finally by Duda and now Knight to c3
now with well with more pressure on the
d5 one night the b6 and here f3 hoping
to get the G file open for example if
captures captures then you will get a
lot of pressure along the G file
so after f3 just Bishop to e6 by Duda
we have castles here Queen side which is
a new move in the game we already
mention V Cuba vs du Bois
III was plated but okay here we have
castles and immediately rook ate the c8
by Duda
here Duda is hoping to grab the night
with rook captures on c3 for example if
white starts something like age four he
wants to push on the King side I we
would most likely see rook captures on
c3 and after B captures now Knight to c4
Knight Knights to c4 just a very nice
night of course threatening Queen to a3
trick followed by Queen to be to mate so
you would have to capture it and after D
captures it would just be a very nice
position for black the Queen a3 is an
idea you're also preparing to push the
e3 pawn this night is coming to d5 it's
gonna be very very hard for white to
play this especially if you have to win
this if you try to hide your King
somewhere on the Kings side still just
III check even you give up a pawn Knight
this coming to d5 and it is gonna be
very hard we need to be 5 defending this
e4 pawn and now even though you have the
two rooks you're not really gonna have
anywhere to use them so after Luke a to
c8 Shawn goes back Queen to d2 not
allowing this rook of sacrifice with a
six by black and the now rook hd1 we're
finally he captures on f3 g captures on
f3 and now night after d7 going for a
night raid here and now she um jars and
just starts pushing on the King side h4
with f6 here trying to get rid of the
night hopefully trade here but of course
she is not interested in that he just
brings the knight back you know it's
very hard for black this Knight really
doesn't have all that many squares this
Knight is in the way the pawn is
covering D squares f6 now prevents the
knife from joining the game so you will
have to decide how to deal with the
night here on d7 we have rush of the f7
by Judah and now Queen to f4 offering a
queen trade we have roped the c6
defending the Queen and here a film
craze we have Queen captures rook
captures and now Knight the c5 and
grabbing even more space attacking the
b7 pawn of course you cannot trade
otherwise you lose material here but
your rook and the night will be under
attack
look the b8 defending the pawn here and
now roofed east 7 again a nice free rook
lift tink the f8 attacking the rook and
now Ruby DT 1 nicely doubling up on the
e-file and here if you look at this
position it's it's extremely hard for
black to make a move
what do you would what do you play here
it's like it's sort of a super Swank and
there are no good moves for black here
for example what can you play if you try
something like Bishop to g6 which seems
like well I'll move you transferred the
bishop to it to a better diagonal then
White has this trick of playing h5 and
now after Bishop captures and this point
I don't know if she um had all of this
planned out at the moment that he played
h4 but you know maybe maybe even he did
would be it would be very impressive but
the point is that you have to give up
this pawn so the bishop cannot use f5 to
defend the knight and e7 because now
when the better of this year you cannot
defend the night with from g4 due to the
pawn here and now you play Bishop to a4
and now the bishop cannot be captured
because the knight captures here with
check will pick up the rook here and
what what else way is there to defend
the night you cannot capture on c5
because again pawn comes with a double
attack so your only option is to bring
the bishop back to it but this doesn't
work because now night night characters
and b7 so what else can you play the
rook is under attack you have to capture
it and then you get rook captures with
Czech king your servant rook check King
g6 rook goes here you're gonna grab this
pawn and slowly but surely you will win
this game and if you don't play
something like this up to g6 you could
try something like h6 is just to wait
and see what happens then Bishop to a4
is strong right away just as the bishop
is not on g6 to be able to defend the
night from f5 you cannot defend it from
here that's covered twice Bishop e8 runs
into the same idea so here Duda tried
the only thing he had left he played
Knight captures on c5 with pawn captures
and now of course his two pieces are
under attack well then I tend the rook
and he played rook to d7 now hoping for
rook captures Knight captures but
without even pausing
the video of course you know what she um
played here without even giving you a
couple of seconds of course you all see
roof captures on f7 just grabbing two
pieces for the rook which is much better
with King captures on f7 as the king is
in check and now see capture son b6 so
now it's a bishop Knight and the rook
against two rooks we rugby to d8 by
Judah and now Knight captures on d5 and
here Knight captures on d5 well usually
you wouldn't really give up two pieces
for a rook but here it's a very special
occasion because here if rook captures
you're gonna go eh for the rook is still
pinned you cannot move it for example
King to f8 unpinning now you will
capture it and after rook captures
you're gonna go rook to d1 as the pawn
endgame is winning for white it's six
against five and you're just gonna start
pushing here the King is gonna help out
on the Kings side if needed and the King
opponent game is winning and if you
decline then rook d7 you go after this
pawn here look e seven look back the d5
and this is just a much better position
for white most likely white will win
this so Duda doesn't like the idea of
grabbing the two pieces for a rope in
this position he plays King to g6 and
okay see for consolidating that d5
square for the knight with King to h5
going for the pawn but now rook to e4
just defending it and unless you can get
some activity for these two rooks
they're just they're just useless
we've looked the c8 now threatening rook
captures here as the C pawn will be
pinned King - D - and now g5 with King -
III unpinning now Knight captures on f6
is a threat which would win the rook
rook the f7 defending the pawn and now H
captures and g5 with F captures and g5
and now Bishop to a for King goes to h6
and now Bishop t8 pushing the row back
rook to f8 and now Bishop to d7
attacking the c8 rook rook back to b8
and now we have before black has no
active moves of white we'll just keep
improving the position kingi 6 and the
now comes night the c7 we have look F to
d8 attacking the bishop and the now rook
to e7 just defending and if the King
moves you're just gonna start gobbling
up pawns we looked h8 defending the h7
pawn now Bush of the EA to check here
came to have sex attacking the rook and
here Knight to d5 check this is move 41
and it was in this position that young
she stopped do that resigned the game
and amazingly Geoffrey Hume was able to
win on demand equalizing the score and
now tomorrow they are going into the
rapid section he resigns as there is not
much to do here your only option is King
at five and then you get Bishop to h5
which is not pleasant
the bishop covers the D squares the
night covers D squares and well King D
four followed by rocky five is checkmate
there's not much you can do about it you
can go something like rookie 18 before
now there's the threat of mate it's not
not easily prevented the g4 doesn't do
anything we're just gonna play a four
keep it keep the the g5 Square closed
and well there's nothing to do you can
try rook captures this but now we're
just down a whole piece and what it's a
completely winning position for white so
of course dude I know is this after
Knight to d5 he resigns and tomorrow
we're gonna see a lot more action
between the two of them in the rapid
section as both both of the games were
pretty insane ah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think ravine arriving three o clock are
camels up costly Mathias craft Ferdinand
Souter and Allen broom for contribution
to my channel thank you what I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos you're thankful for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the feeder World Cup we're
gonna check at least one more game from
this round as we do have to check out
the standings also you know checking up
on your suggestions and following up on
anything else that had that's happening
in the chess world so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day